when you drive around Madagascar you see
the land burning you see fires burning
all over the country everywhere you go
people are burning down the forest for
farmland it's a type of slash and burn
agriculture called toddy and it's the
biggest threat to lemurs in Madagascar
Tavia slash and burn agriculture you
chopped on the force if you're a farmer
because it makes the land more fertile
and then you plant rice but erosion
occurs and the steep slopes and so all
of that for Jodi is washed away next
year perhaps you can plant second crop
the third year maybe not so then as
you'll need to move from this piece of
land to another piece of land slashing
and burning and starting the process
again
my eyes are burning it's so hot down
there it's really oh it's most people
don't know about lemurs and they don't
even know what Madagascar is so this
film will bring to our global audience
the fact that lemurs are so special I
mean there's a hundred and three species
and more than half are in serious danger
of extinction that means they'll be gone
from our Earth's forever if we don't
help